Narrator: The Battle of Winterfell,
which took place during
season eight, episode
three, "The Long Night,"
was the most epic battle
on "Game of Thrones" yet.
The production was, to say the least,
a brutal labor of love.
Here are just a few of the
most amazing things about it
and how they were brought to life.
Warning: spoilers ahead.
Over the course of 11 weeks,
a cast and crew of 750 people
worked in the worst
imaginable weather conditions,
battling freezing temperatures
and all the elements, to make history.
Director Miguel Sapochnik,
who has directed
some of the most legendary
"Thrones" episodes to date,
took the helm here.
In order to keep off the undead army,
a giant moat was created
around Winterfell.
The wights famously do not like fire,
so to keep them away, Melisandre
lights it all on fire.
Yes, the fire you saw was real.
In order to achieve this effect,
they used about 900 steel logs.
They chose steel instead of wood
as they would appear to catch fire
without completely burning away.
To make the fire spread
in the first place,
they filled water troughs
with gallons and gallons of propane.
The fire was important
to add light to a battle
that was mostly shot in the dark of night,
a fact that has been controversial
for "Game of Thrones" fans
as it made it hard to know
what was happening at times.
Cinematographer Fabian Wagner told Wired,
"The showrunners decided that
this had to be a dark episode,"
and, "Everything they wanted
the audience to see is there."
A lot of dead bodies
pile up in this episode,
and the crew used practical
effects whenever they could.
Many of the wights that
pop up in the crypt
were heavily inspired by
the look of ancient mummies,
decaying skin and all.
The wights were mostly a
combination of prosthetics and CGI.
Prop dead bodies, meanwhile,
are not easy to handle.
They're expensive, heavy,
and hard to move around.
The prop makers came up with a trick
following the Battle of the Bastards.
Instead of having to stick
individual bodies up,
they would stack up a mound of dummies
and create a detailed mold of them.
The team created around
300 of these body piles.
This episode wasn't going to end
without the death of a fan favorite,
and "The Long Night" gave us the demise
of Lyanna Mormont, played by Bella Ramsey,
who sacrifices herself to
kill off the giant wight.
Achieving this involved
complicated and groundbreaking CGI.
They shot a piece of the scene on location
in order to get the backdrop.
While on set, a crew member
held a giant head on a tall pole.
While this was happening,
the camera operators were using Incam.
This technology allowed
them to play back animation
of what the giant's
performance would look like
that was then synced to the camera.
This allowed the camera operators
to actually see the giant
at his proper scale while on set.
Then, against a green
screen, actor Ian Whyte,
who is over 7 feet tall,
actually played the giant.
He was filmed in a way
that made him seem like
he was double his size.
Ramsey wasn't actually on set with him,
so for the shots where
the giant picks her up,
he instead lifted up a green doll
covered in tracking markers.
That scene was then motion-captured.
In the final layer, for closeup shots,
Ramsey was lifted up
by a giant robotic arm
that picked her up and moved
her exactly as the giant would.
The giant wasn't even close
to the biggest creature
involved in the battle.
There were the three dragons,
Rhaegal, Drogon, and Viserion.
Famously, whenever you see shots of
Jon and Daenerys riding the dragons,
in reality, they're actually riding on
what looks like a big mechanical bull.
They also actually shoot fire on set.
The rest of what you see on screen
as well as the color of Viserion's flames
is largely a result of CGI.
Animating Viserion breathing fire
differed from the two alive dragons.
Part of that was because
Viserion breathes blue fire,
but also, this dragon is
injured. He's leaking,
as VFX supervisor Joe Bauer points out.
He has a hole in his neck,
and he's missing half his face
by the time Jon Snow comes
face-to-face with him.
You can see fire coming out of
different parts of his face.
The damage caused by the dragon's fire
was added by production designers.
They walked around with flamethrowers
and covered rubble with dirt and mud.
"After 20 minutes of watching
a battle, you're over it,"
Sapochnik said to Entertainment Weekly.
So how do you stop it from
being a battle in that sense?
The biggest inspiration for this battle
was the Battle of Helm's Deep
from the "Lord of the
Rings: The Two Towers,"
which Sapochnik notes is actually
three different intercut battles.
But that doesn't mean the action
wasn't incredibly important.
The star of the episode
might've been Maisie Williams,
whose Arya Stark delivers the fatal blow
to the Night King that saves Winterfell.
It was a long road for Williams
leading to this episode.
She said the director called her
a year before "The Long
Night" started shooting
and told her to start training,
but she had no idea what
exactly she was training for.
To prepare for some of
the set's tight spaces,
weapons master Tommy Dunne
gave Arya a staff that would disassemble,
allowing her to fight in narrow spaces.
With the exception of some of
the more dangerous moments,
Williams does most of her own stunts.
In fact, she's so committed to Arya
that the right-handed Williams
learned how to fight left-handed
just so she could fight the
same way Arya did in the books.
When she took down the Night King,
she was attached to a wire
and launched into him.
That sequence was mostly shot
in front of a green screen
so the crew could have better
control over the environment.